such clothes which expose the upper part
of the chest the cleavage and the
shoulder. So is it halal or haram? I
believe the question posed is talking
about a
tailor stitching clothes for a lady
where the upper part of the chest is
seen and the cleavage and the shoulder
are seen. So is it halal to stitch such
clothes? First you should realize what
is the purpose of these clothes.
Normally when you stitch undergarments
but naturally it's possible to show the
clothing then it's perfectly fine
because the clothes worn are under the
other clothes but if there are other
clothes where you know that a lady is
wearing clothes only amongst the ladies
and if some part of the body is exposed
then it's not haram but wearing such
clothes otherwise outside it is not
permitted. So depending upon the clothes
that if you know that you're stitching
clothes for ladies are going to wear an
abai on top of that then it's perfectly
fine. But if you know that you're
stitching designer clothes and people
wear these clothes not wearing a coat
over it or wearing an abai over it and
if you're aware of it stitching such
clothes is not permitted because Allah
says in the Quran in surah maida chapter
number 5 verse number two that help one
another in righteousness and tawa do not
help one another in f and ranker. So if
you're making clothes which you're aware
that ladies will be wearing for parties
and exposing the bodies and would be
involved in things which are haram then
it is not correct to stitch such
clothes. But if you know these clothes
are worn at home the ladies are going to
wear it in front of the nam. There are
some Muslim countries where people wear
a so if you know that it is not going to
involve any haram action then there's no
problem. But if you're aware that this
will be worn by ladies who normally go
for parties outside and they don't wear
the hijab and you're specially catering
to them then it is not permitted for you
to help them in doing haram activity you
should not stitch that clothes. So
depending upon how it's going to be used
and you as a tailor know better your
customers. So based on that you have to
decide whether what you're doing is
haram or allah.